Allah says inah Imran chapter number 3
verse 110
oh you Muslims e are the best of peoples
evolved for mankind Allah has given us
an honor and calling us Muslims as the
best of people whenever there is honor
it is always followed up with
responsibility there is no honor without
responsibility so when Allah is giving
such a great honor to us and calling us
the kra um the the best of peoples is
isn't there any responsibility the reply
is again the same verse
because we enjoy what is good and we
forbid what is wrong and we believe in
Allah if we do not enjoy what is good
and if we do not forbid what is wrong if
we don't do dawa we are not fit to be
called as Muslims we aren't fit to be
called as hraumah d'wa is compulsory for
every Muslim and inshallah my son
shikari will speak about it in more
detail. It is
Allah says in surah bakar chapter 2
verse number 143 that we have made you
an aim of community so that you may be a
witness over the nations and the
messenger will be a witness over you
it's our duty to convey the message of
Allah subhana wa t'ala
and our life the Islamic life is a
balanced life unlike other beliefs
it either talks about the body of
fulfillment of the soul. Islam
the solution is for the body and for the
soul.
A beloved prophet said it's mentioned in
say bkari volume number three hadith
number 1975
the bel prophet said abdullah one of the
sabas may Allah be with him I have heard
that you fast all days and pray full
nights he said yeah the prophet said do
not do it fast one day do not fast the
next day pray part of the night sleep
for part of the night your body has
right over do your wife has right over
you. So Islam is a justly balanced
religion. It doesn't believe in
monasticism. Doesn't believe in
renouncing the world. The dunya in Islam
is part of the dean.
It is a holistic solution.
And furthermore, when we see when people
talk about happiness, talking about
billionaires,
we know the example of Christina on
who inherited wealth after her father
died who was a billionaire and during
interview she was asked that you are the
richest woman in the world. She said yes
I'm the richest woman in the world but
also the most unhappiest woman in the
world.
She didn't get peace. She didn't get
happiness and later on she committed
suicide and this is common family
problems and all more in the rich than
the poor. It's there in both but rich
wealth does not get you happiness.
Allah says the wealth is a fit is a test
for you.
And Allah says in the Quran
in surah chapter number 13 verse number
28 verily in the remembrance of Allah do
hearts find contentment.
Verily in the remembrance of Allah do
And that reminds me of a very good
example of one of the greatest scholars
of the medieval age.
And we knew he lived a life of poverty.
He was imprisoned. He was threatened by
his enemy. He was tortured.
So when the enemy threatened him, what
did she
said?
He said that what can you do to me? What
can you do to me? If you imprison me, if
you put me in jail, I would do zikar of
Allah,
zikar, praise
and remember Allah.
If you exile me, I would
I would contemplate on the creation of
Allah. If you execute me, I would be a
shahid. I would be a martyr. My ja is in
my heart. Imagine
a person who's not afraid of dying.
Whatever you want to do, you do. You
cannot take away the ja.
My ja is in my heart and I'm not of this
dy. I'm for a so this is true happiness.
Even though he lived in poverty, even
though he was taught and if you read the
statement of
may Allah have mercy on him, he was one
of the well-known students of Shik
Islamia, he says
the life that Shik islamy lived of
poverty he was imprisoned but I've never
seen in my life any man who's more
happier
than
imagine life of poverty being tortured
to give up his mission. He didn't budge.
If you imprison me, I will do of Allah.
If you exile me,
I will contemplate on the creation of
Allah. If you execute me, I'll be
shahid. My ja is in my heart. So you
cannot take away his ja.
So this is true happiness.